[موسيقى]
أجنبي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
لذا فإن هذه البدلة مختلفة قليلاً
عن بدلات Uh اليوم
المستخدمة في محطة الفضاء ، وهذا ما
يسمى بتصميم الدخول الخلفي ، حيث يتم
تثبيت الضوء المرتبط بمجموعة الواقي
في الخوذة  فقاعة آه وهذا
يعطي رواد الفضاء الأضواء
لمعرفة مكان وجودهم في الأجزاء المظللة
من القمر أو إذا كانوا في
مدار أرضي منخفض في ممر ليلي ، يمكنهم تشغيل
هذه الأضواء لرؤية باستخدام الأدوات
والاستمرار في تحسين ذلك  هذا
جزء ممتاز من فريق xcmu الذي قام بعمل
هائل وقام الكثير من
زملائنا بعمل هائل في تصميم
تلك الأحذية خاصة للأسباب الحرارية
لذلك لم يرغب أي شخص في
اختلاط هذا الأمر ولكن بخلاف ذلك
أعتقد أن هذا مجرد
بدلة رائعة المظهر رائعة ،
هناك مجموعة متنوعة من المفاصل التي
وضعناها أيضًا في مجموعة الجذع السفلي
وسيكون هذا
تحسينًا كبيرًا على بدلات Apollo
لم يكن لدى بدلات Apollo الكثير من هذه